can we observe for a short period of
time there's no limit as far as the
period of is concern you can offera for
the short period or for long period for
a short while the majority of Scholars
agree it can even for a short while even
for one hour Allah be pleased with him
he said that can be done for one hour
but there are certain Scholars who say
that should be done minimum for one day
or for days and they say this one hour
is actually a period doesn't refer to a
day
but the majority of Scholars agree it
can be done for a short time for one
hour for a day for a few days for a week
for 10 days for a month it depends upon
the person there's no limitation as far
as the p is
concerned doctor